.
WELCOME TO JILL BIDEN'S AMERICA.
>> BEAT.
>> GUYS, HEY.
>> TICKET LOOK AT THIS
DISTURBING VIDEO OUT OF LOS
ANGELES.
HE IS RUNNING FOR HIS LIFE TO
CARS FLYING PALESTINIAN FLAGS G
FOR HIM.
>> THEY WEREN'T SEEING ANY
RACIAL SLURS.
THEY SAID THEY WOULD LIKE TO
COMMIT A TERRORISTIC ATTACK.
>> SO MANY VICIOUS ATTACKS
AGAINST JEWISH AMERICANS.
THE FACT IS ANTI- SEMITISM HAS
BEEN COMFORTABLY HOUSED INSIDE
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT.
'S BEEN CELEBRATED BY THE
ACTIVISTS THE DEMOCRATS RIGHT
NOW ARE OBSESSING ON A MISSION
TO INVEST IN THE CAPITAL RIOT
THAT NOW THEY ARE TURNING A
BLIND EYE TO THE EXPLOSION.
THEY REFUSE TO CONFRONT THE
ANTI- SEMITIC CROSSCURRENTS.
BY REFUSING TO RENOUNCE THE FAR
LESS PUSH TO DEFUND THE POLICE
AND A TARGET POLICE PRACTICES.
THEY HAVE MADE LIFE IN AMERICA
MORE DANGEROUS FOR EVERYBODY.
BY REFUSING TO CALL OUT THE
ANTI- JEWISH SENTIMENT THEY HAV
MADE AMERICA FAR MORE DANGEROUS
FOR A JEWISH PERSON.
THE ORIGINS OF THIS TRACK THE
TACTIC OF BLACK LIVES MATTER
PEOPLE LAST SUMMER.
A LARGE CARAVAN OF PEOPLE WAVIN
PALESTINIAN FLAGS AS THEY DROVE
THROUGH SEVERAL NEIGHBORHOODS
MEMBERS OF THE CARAVAN WERE
THROWING BOTTLES AT RESTAURANTS.
THEY USED ANTI-SEMITIC SLURS.
IT WAS A HATE CRIME THAT WAS
PREPARED.
THEY CAME TO FIGHT WITH JEWISH.
DOZENS OF MEN RAN FROM THE
CARAVAN AND THE RESTAURANT
ASKING WHO IS JEWISH?
DOES THAT REMIND YOU OF
ANYTHING?
IN BOTH CASES THESE INTIMIDATIO
TACTICS GO UNPUNISHED.
THE AGITATORS FEEL EMPOWERED.
THEY HAD THE COMFORT OF MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS.
>> PALESTINIANS UNDERSTAND
OCCUPATION OF THEIR LAND IS A
REALITY OF HAVING TO GO THROUGH
CHECKPOINTS WHILE PEOPLE LIVE
THEIR LIVES.
THEY KNOW THIS IS REALITY.
AND REALITY IS SO MUCH MORE.
WHEN THEY SHOWED UP IN THE
FERGUSON IN 2014 WITH SO MANY
OTHERS.
>> THE ALSO HAVE THE SAME
SYSTEMIC RACISM ANALOGY.
>> WHEN JIM CROW ENDED IT ENDED
THE EXISTENCE AND CONVINCED A
VERY RACIST SYSTEM TO CONTINUE.
>> WITH THE RACIAL GRIEVANCE
INDUSTRY IN THE US ANTI- JEWISH
FORCES USED VIRAL VIDEO CLIPS I
AN ATTEMPT TO INDOCTRINATE THE
NEXT GENERATION.
>> THEY CAN'T AND SEE WHAT THEY
ARE SEEING ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THEY ARE SEEING A VERY
REMARKABLE IN PARTICULAR THE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
THEY ARE ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
>> MEANWHILE THIS ANTI-SEMITE
ACCUSED ISRAEL OF RUNNING AN
APARTHEID STATE AND ENGAGING IN
TERRORISM AND THEN DEMANDED
ISRAEL'S ANSWER BE FOR WAR
CRIMES.
LAST SHE REVEALED HOW THIS
RADICALISM DOES SHARE A COMMON
CAUSE WITH THIS.
>> THIS IS INTERCONNECTED WITH
BLACK AND BROWN BUSINESSES.
WHAT THEY DO TO THE PALESTINIAN
PEOPLE IS WHAT THEY CONTINUE TO
DO TO OUR BLACK BROTHERS AND
SISTERS.
IN FACT THE COFOUNDER SITES ARE
TRIPPED THE PALESTINE IS A KEY
INFLUENCE.
>> IS TRANSFORMED ALL OF US.
TO TRANSFORM HOW WE THE
PALESTINIAN STRUGGLE BUT ALSO
HOW WE UNDERSTOOD THE
RELATIONSHIP OF BLACK PEOPLE'S
STRUGGLE IN THE US.
I THINK IT WAS A PROFOUND MOMEN
OF CLARITY.
IT'S BEEN VERY POWERFUL FOR THE
MOVEMENT.
>> THEY'VE BEEN THE MOST LOYAL
ALLY FOR US DRINKS TRUMPS
FIRST-TERM THEY SAID PROGRESS
WOULD BE MADE SLOWLY BUT SURELY.
BUT THE NEW PRESIDENT IS WELL O
HIS WAY TO FOLDING.
HE'S REFUSING TO TACKLE THE
SOCIAL MYTHOLOGY AT THE SOURCE.
SPAWNED A TERRIFYING OF ANTI-
SEMITIC ATTACK